buying a car can be a stressful time but
the people at chapman automotive want to
make it as easy as possible and joining
us now is don hamrick president of
nevada operations welcome it's good to
see you we were just talking a little
bit on during the break about the car
buying situation now things are better
aren't they things are better for us
yeah we've been very fortunate cars are
starting to roll in we're ordering
vehicles up for customers and it's going
to be a little while before the supply
is completely back but for us we're
making things happen we're helping
customers dreams come true and a lot of
people have been talking about rising
inflation how are prices right now in
the car market so prices are still up a
little bit
what we're doing to combat that is we've
got a a program i'm calling it free ride
and and so 90 days no payments so you
buy your car you take delivery you have
90 days before you make a payment and
then on top of that we're giving you 90
days worth of free gas and that's saying
something nowadays because i'm sure
you've seen the prices at the bottom oh
my gosh are you kidding me 90 days of
free gas 90 days of free gas and 90 days
no payments it's a free ride that is
literally a free ride i don't see
incentives like that that's pretty
amazing we're excited and our customers
have been excited that's the best part
mercedes they love it that is fantastic
can you um tell us about the new
dealership how is it coming along so it
is coming along fabulously we are going
to move in next week and uh it's amazing
it's 70 000 square feet it's going to be
so great for our employees so great for
our customers
beautiful coffee area beautiful a lounge
for our clients 31 brand new service
baits that are huge so customers are
going to be able to get their cars in
and out the same day
60
i mean a huge uh parts facility so i'll
have everything that customers need to
get their repairs done while they wait
saving money saving time we love that so
now that you have this new dealership
opening what's going to happen to the
current location i'm going to let you in
a little secret okay so our store on
saharan mojave
is going to become an exclusive
jeep store so we are going to completely
remodel that store we break ground july
15th next month and that store will be
come just a jeep store and you know we
have so many great products in the jeep
lineup with the wrangler the grand
cherokee the all-new grand wagoneer and
wagoneer and so those vehicles will be
exclusively located at chapman jeep on
east sahara mojave that store will be
completed before this year is over that
is so fantastic
congratulations on all of your success
take a free ride with chapman automotive
that is the way to go for sure thank you
chapman automotive for sponsoring this
segment call them
702-457-1061 or go to las vegas dodge
dot com free ride for 90 days no
payments and free gas for 90 days with a
new per car purchase or lease we'll be
right back
[Music]